Robert said, he's got clicks, but no phone calls.
Can you assist?
So guys, one thing I would love to just try
and just reiterate that something that I've tried
to really focus on is try to just,
whenever you have an issue in your business,
try to just use your intuition and think, okay.
And by the way, this goes for anything.
If you're not, if your business owners aren't closing,
but you're getting a bunch of people to a closing call,
then you could use the same exact logic, okay?
But with this situation, you're like, okay,
I'm getting clicks, but no phone calls.
So that means that people are clicking on my ads
and I'm getting no phone calls.
So well, then you start kind of digging deeper.
You go, all right, well, assuming that these people
are visiting my website, then that would mean
that I'm either getting the wrong people to my website,
right, because they're just not, they're not ready to buy.
They're not ready to call for an estimate.
So that could be number one.
The other thing is I have the right people,
but my landing page isn't converting, right?
So that's what you have to look at
and you have to kind of be logical about it, okay?
So what I would recommend is there's a couple
of different things that you can do.
If you have an idea that maybe your website's
not converting, you can go,
there's a software called Hotjar.
You can install Hotjar on your,
and there's other ones too,
but you can install Hotjar on your website.
You can track and look at what people,
you know, when they come to the page,
what are they doing?
Are they scrolling below the fold?
Are they doing this?
Are they doing that?
Whatever.
So that's an idea.
If you think it's a conversion issue,
if you think it's maybe the wrong type of customer,
or you think they're clicking on the ad
and they're not going to the website, for example,
I know sometimes I used to think it was my competitors,
maybe you could go and you could set up your analytics.
You could see, are you getting, you know,
how much traffic are you actually getting?
Is it increasing?
Is it lining up with how many clicks you're getting?
And you just kind of have to dissect it from there
and you just have to do a process of elimination.
But if you guys are using the core keywords,
you guys are following the training,
most likely you have the right traffic going to your website,
which means that you have a conversion issue,
which then I would go, hey, is your website,
you know, something that's actually converting,
is it user friendly?
Is it something that is scaring people off?
Is the number easy to find?
Is the quote form easy to find?
Or are you burying the stuff at the bottom,
making it difficult?
So you just kind of have to use your intuition there.
Go look at some of our example websites.
You can go look at BentonvilleConcrete.com.
It doesn't have to be complicated.
It's very simple.
I promise you guys, even the ugly websites convert.
So that's kind of how I would attack that.
But that's a really good question, Robert.